I'm here in East Flores and to my right
you can see Mount leat toi Lil laki the
volcano has been erupting consistently
since December and as you can see now
it's erupting again you can see the
thick gray smoke coming from the volcano
and we can also hear this steady loud
grumbling as the volcano continues to
erup in early January authorities
increased the alert level of the volcano
to the highest possible warning status
and the regional government has urged
people not to go within 5 km of the
volcano's crater it has also warned
people to be on alert for further cold
lava floods if Heavy Rain
occurs seismic data indicates a
significant increase in low frequency
earthquakes that means the movement of
magma is intensifying experts say this
means the volume of lava is likely to
increase more than 6,300 people have
been evacuated from their homes in
villages close to the volcano
Jessica Washington aler East Flores
Indonesia